well first of all you don't mind
after having got the news from Paris I
recalled I remember a poem written by my
native competitors the Nobel Prize
winner poet this visca version Burtka
and thank you church from your staff who
in the half an hour supplied me from the
computer the poem hatred if you don't
mind I share with you some hatred
look how how able and skilled is in our
century she hated see how efficient is
still is
I would keep itself in shape our
century's hatred how easily devolves the
tallest obstacles how rapidly pulses
tracks us down
hatred hated its face twisted in degrees
of erotic ecstasy gifted diligent
hard-working need you mentioned all the
songs it has composed of the pages it
has edit our history books of the human
carpets it has spread over countless
city squares and football fields hate it
is a master of contest between
explorance
and that quite red blood and white snow
above all it never tires of its light
motives the impeccable executioner
towering over its old victim the last
words it's always ready for new
challenges if it has to wait a while it
will they say it's blind blind it has a
sniper skin sight and gazes attentively
at the future as only it can so first
migration was hated and then before I
will ask you a question I want to show
you with you something else from my
experience you mentioned
my participation in the matter of the
leaders in the Markham Sabbath
Montgomery in 65 before I arrived I went
to Mississippi to the deep south it did
it for the time for the young people to
know radiuses it the battle for civil
rights in the United States I came with
a Volkswagon old folks when useful magna
I remember I voted for had purchased it
for $110 and I because it was used in 65
and then I went to Magnolia Mississippi
universities where was set fire in a
school where the black kids cried for
three together with a white and when I
left the car there was somebody set fire
to my car why because next to me was a
[ __ ] boy was next to me so when I
remembered son Burke has hated I can
only also remember when I was the object
of hated but this is what is behind
hated and then believe me from those
days I was starting I started thinking
why people do it why what the psychology
in the deep south I could understand for
the white fool people
if they wanted to distinguish their only
value was their white skin nothing else
so when they see interests coping with
the equalization of rights say opposes
they rejected it and what do I value
value by my whiteness being a white man
probably for sure it happens in very
many other fields in very many other
situations and here I want to tell you
that is as far as I'm concerned people
are much more obsessed when they are
humiliated than they are killed and
believe me if we want to avoid the
ultimate danger start with trying with
was trying to comprehend to the total to
to develop empathy to not to humilate
the other person because this is
stronger
the final word for my final question
Miriam because I am fascinated by you
facing the worst barbarism
what kept you alive was it the beauty
he's talking about was it
sheer luck what is it well some people
would say Providence well in my well
maybe fortune good luck but in my case
I'm sorry I maybe I would be a little
battle a friend of mine excuse me for
giving this parallel a friend of mine
whose autobiography was translated into
very many languages it is autobiography
with the sky man twisting in his memoirs
who possess a boat I did
his only conclusions in a hell should
behave according to the laws to the
rules of the hell no rules only you can
survive if you kill somebody else
fortunately fortunately really it was my
fortune my luck that I passed the two
death marches to campus houses and
bundled in a group of cameras of my
college and I will give you only one
example and that you will know what I
have in mind after having arrived to our
faith after three-four days
a couple who was a criminal and who use
a German slang I couldn't follow his
land order something I didn't follow him
but I didn't understand him so he
knocked me down I fell down my glasses
were broken and low for somebody who is
short-sighted without glasses symmetry
one day two days he would be beaten up
to death so there was one chance to get
glasses
well of course to the young generation
fact that no possibility to go to a
petition no possibility but there was a
possibility to get glasses from the dead
bodies and people who you know in houses
it was called Canada this unit to
detachment with 4 - sorting the what was
left
they wouldn't say there were no people
good house they wouldn't give you
glasses from the dead body they wanted
to sell it all of the currency among the
elite and they in the game was even
vodka those who were interval civilians
if not vodka from me were cigarettes we
didn't have cigarettes we were just in
the bottom on the bottom but still we
have also can see what was the currency
bread because every day portion as they
demanded see portions for glasses from a
dead body if I had to give [ __ ]
portions I would die and the 10 people
my 10 coverage decided they they will
cut once one Church of the 10 portions
to give and over
to purchase obtain glasses for me for
myself so my conclusion is very
optimistic this one so that maybe maybe
this also made me going in 65 as much
Miss Martin Luther King from a lot
probably this was trouble so in this
case I would be adopted and in general I
am not so much because you touched the
issue of culture and what a comparison
Timbuktu is something this is really a
great movie but 95% of the ordinary
would see Horrors they would be infected
by all the power films criminal feelings
so and here I agree with you we could
say as actors answers it has been
already in their own times it was two
great performances maybe this is a great
performance of the Internet of the
television Cavan consulates we should
think what to do with it with with this
great information of the tabloids of the
this is the first step of Barbara
digital step
you